[Music]
driven by technological advances the
cloud computing capabilities the rise
of AI is undeniable not a
day ago without hearing about
topics around said tears or
strengthening their league  the symbolism
and others there are some notable successes,
moreover widely publicized but the
deployment on the scale remains nevertheless
limited why in fact two essential reasons
the first is what confidence
can we grant to these systems there and the
second  it is what level
of industrialization we give it in
critical systems where trust
is essential
it is absolutely essential to be
able to offer a set of tools and
that within the framework of trust
point programs and that is one of the main objectives
therefore  a set of tools which allow
not only to design but to
validate certified and to explain this is
the objective in fact of what
this prat steria will provide in this context the
platform which will be  has built will
allow all manufacturers to
focus in fact on their
business issues and to be able,
at the end of their data operations, to
have systems for which they will validate the
conformity but also which will provide the
confidence necessary for their adoption.
[Music]